ぱぱぱぱ
え。え。
知らないおじさんがついてくる、なんか家の前で叫んでるよ。一人で危険を感じてる。
まじで危ないやつじゃん!!!!!!!!!!!!
逃げて!!!!!!wwwwwwwwwww
あっこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
いやっマジで大丈夫か？
ほんとにやばいときはすぐ警察に言いましょうね
あの～　何度も登場していますが
絶対ゲロの出る液体
以前、臭い無くすために本気で消臭を
色々ぶち込んで見たんですけども
今どうなってんだろ？
ちょっと 現、今ちょっとどうなってんのかわかんないんでちょっと見てみましょう
・・・・
量が増えてる
そうか、いろいｒ、、オ‘‘ォ‘‘ェ‘‘
オ‘‘オ‘‘ォ‘‘エ‘‘ェ‘‘
え、やばい
まじでちょっと待って
オゥップ
オォ、、おえぇぇぇ（嘔吐）
ちょっと出ちゃった
待って、、助けて―――!!
だれか――――!!!
たなっち!!!
オゥエェェェ
ェェ、、、、ガハッ！
ペッ　ウエェ、ウッ　ウ　ガァゴホン　ベッ
た）綺麗にしたんじゃなかったっけ？
は）嫌っ消臭をがっつりかけても
は）尚、、、
た）はぁ～～（溜め息）
は）一回嗅いでみよ、一回開けます
は）まだまだまだ
た）ウ‘‘ゥ‘‘ガッ
た）う‘‘う‘‘ぅぅガハッ
た）ウ‘‘ウ‘‘ゥゥガハッ
は）ウ‘‘ウ‘‘ゥ‘‘ゥゥゥエェェっング　ガハッガハ
え、、いつの？
た）いつの？
消臭ビーズたくさん入れて消臭
消臭スプレーがん掛けしてもほぼ
う‘‘ぅ‘‘ぅ‘‘
ほぼ意味がない状態でございます
どうすればいいんだ!!!!!!!!
と、僕が考えたところ
更なる消臭グッズを見つけてきました
こちら！
臭いが消える魔法の粉
❚完全消臭❚
いやっ！これなんか
靴の臭い匂いを消す
前回やった消臭スプレー消臭ビーズとか
とはまた違う方向性の臭いの消し方です
でもまだ臭いのベクトルが違うんで
今回これで効くのかどうか試してみたいと
思います
そこそこ沢山準備させていただきました
この粉を入れて臭いが無くなれば一番Happyかなって思っております
ﾊｧﾊｧ
マジこれ嗅がせてあげたい
いろんな人に
あれだけ消臭ビーズと消臭スプレーうってもまだ
健在なんですよ臭いが
やぁあんたどうしようもねぇよ
オワッ！
前回消臭ビーズとスプレー入れすぎたせいで
あの、物量的には
かなり多くなってしまいました
果たして今回、この闇の根源を
断つことができるのでしょうか
GO!!
とりあえず開けてみましょう
まずはお前の力を
知りたいんだよね
おぅ
いやこれ大丈夫か~？
絵だけ見るとちょっとほんとはっきりと
なめ腐ってんです
でも案外こういうやつがすごい強いってことが
多いんですよね
おぉ～
普通に粉だ
どこにでもよく
取引されてる普通の粉ですね
とりあえずぶち込めばぶち込むほど
なんか臭いが無くなる感じかな
では、早速粉をかけていきましょう
まず普通にこれちょびっとかけたぐらいじゃ
変わんないと思うんですけど
とりあえずちょびっとかけてみ、、
オオオォィ
とりあえずちょっとかけてみることから
始めてみます
いきます
ちょっとかけてみました
これでまず臭いが変わっているのか
確かめてみましょう
スン
オ``ォ``ォ``
すいません無理でした
次はもう丸々一本をいきます
一本をいってダメだったら
けっこう詰みですからね
いきます
よし
やばい　盛り塩みたになってるんで
一回閉じて振りましょう
ファッファッファッ!!!!!!
はい　というわけで振りました
じゃあいきます
それじゃあ嗅いでみます
え、、？
待って
あれ？あれ？待って
ウ``ウ``ゥ``ゥ``ゥ``ゥ``
ダメだ　一本ごときじゃ何も変わらん事が分かった
全部いきます！！！
待ってこれ物量的に大丈夫か?
ちょっと液体を減らします
まってヤバイおぉーとめっちゃちょっと待ってヤバイ
ヤバイヤバイ
あぁ　待ってやばい
ヤバイ、、ヤバイ、、ヤバイ、、ヤバイ、、
いやこれはいったでしょ
もう、あれですからね
液体の要素がほぼ無くなってきてますから
これでまだ臭いが無くなってなかったら
僕もうけっこう厳しいとこありますよ
おし
振ります!
しゃぁ
どうだ
長年の時を経て
ようやくこの長、、、
ちょっちょっちょ待って待って待って
ようやくこの永い戦いに勝負をつける時が来たようだ
果たして
〔絶対ゲロの出る臭い〕は
大量の臭いが消える魔法の粉で
かき消すことができるのか
いきます！！
おわっなんか泡が立ってる
オ``オ``オ``ォ``ォ``ォ``ォ``ウ``ゥ``ゥ``ゥ``
ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓　ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓（ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑）
ぺー↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↓　ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺー↑（ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓　ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓　）
ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↑ぺー↓　ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺー↑ぺー↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺー↓ぺ↑ぺ↓（ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓　ぺ↓ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓　ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺ↑ぺー↑　ぺー↑ぺー↓　ぺ）
ぺ↑ぺ↓ぺ↓ぺ↓
ぺ・ぺ・ぺ・ペン☆
アアァァァァァ、、、、、
無理だ